fish shriek and the plenary first up was
a vote on the Common Fisheries Policy
but also another vote on deep-sea
fishing there are two arguments of a
deep-sea fishing and a Northeast
Atlantic to protect the livelihood of
fishermen or destroy the environment but
intense opposition to plans to ban
bottom trawling in the deep blue seas
left a watered-down compromised offered
little environmental protection despite
being voted through by any Peas on
Tuesday the ban on bottom trawling this
was rejected the industry one but now
it's the time for the truth for the
council so it's now back in the hands of
member states could abortion be declared
a human right in Europe for the
Conservatives the mayor idea of it went
against European values and they
protested against plans to safeguard
sexual and reproductive rights which
included better education and access
treatment for adolescents at the vote on
Tuesday the report was thrown out ainda
smelly boys Oh parliamentary approval
wrote re o con con todo su yen ta
automail induce militarism rossetto
significa que el morado sound the lamp
it is a tragedy laid bare Europe's
problems with illegal migration in the
waters of the Mediterranean MEP s from
the civil liberties committee have voted
in favor plans to support a cent of
binding search and rescue rules for
Europe there are several member states
who are blocking a decision we are
speaking about all the front X operation
that means we are speaking about border
control but on in those operations if we
F de need we have to save